favorite movie Gone with the Wind no no
no take that back why did I say that
know what that's important to keep in
mind I hate that movie that just came
out I didn't mean that and we all like
butter fight between character and now
my favorite movie is Wizard of Oz Wizard
of Oz and then grease and then Mommy
Dearest favorite food enchiladas
favorite TV show going girls what cracks
you up
Oh irreverence stupidity and I love the
twist of a face like a portmanteau my
favorite word ever is Mexican favorite
word I know I can't stop saying it what
makes you cry oh please thank you in a
favorite wig Oh what you know all the
wigs it's not they're never just one
link that the girls are the problem
girls they're always too so and a lot of
these wigs I've had for over 20 years
some of them and these are synthetic so
they they laugh there's one that really
paid the mortgage on my condo here in
she's up apricot synthetic leg that I
got 23 years ago and you've seen this
wig trust me we have see that and it's
the right color it's the right color
with the brown of my skin it is I don't
even have a name for I think I just call
our apricot what is a good day a good
day is walking down Broadway with my
[Music]
actually the underrated are they I don't
think so I think in the sense that
they've sold millions of Records but if
you put them in the pantheon of the
great all-time rock top artists they
don't always make it to known I even
know the lyrics and the melodies yeah
that the brothers give me along with
beyond but see because people always
just think of the disco era but there's
so much more than the destroyer would be
on when is the last time you've heard um
inside I love you inside and out do I
fight my vicodin
it is transcendent beyond what is the
one thing people don't know about the
noi people is that I am I am more to
myself I know how to emulate human
behavior and because people like Bali
like love people I want to do this
they're easy people couldn't do that
with just I liked it if you can't do
that I'm like you're slowing me down I
need to leave you